[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guests this week is a
comedian podcaster entrepreneur and one
of the people behind Made in Chelsea
Frances bull welcome to trigonometry
hello I'm an expert
well we're about to find out tell us a
little bit about who you are how are you
where you are what's been your journey
through life so what so my background is
I guess in entrepreneurship I left out
of started business and then went into
development with the production company
in London to make a show which was
focused around young entrepreneurs a
special show we focus on young
entrepreneurs in London anyway that
turned out to be made in Chelsea which
was a very different sort of six months
in a reality TV show which was which was
fun and was a amazing experience and I
left you know a couple of times we had a
business down in West Africa ding Gold
expiration doing some conservation for
pangolins as in critically endangered
animal down in West well did you get in
the virtue signaling I did try it for a
bit but then I just felt so weak lost my
mojo III I didn't feel you know the sort
of picture of health ever and said I
would when I became
yeah but you know I people want to do
that I think everyone's bodies are
different and and some people don't need
creating and anyway so you you did some
workout in Africa sorry I interrupted
you keep going yeah so I saw I had a
mining exploration business down there
and in Ghana my background is in mining
and precious metals gold and gold
trading and then after that the sort of
price of God crashed when I was out
there and I came back here and started a
side a business called Yoshi cider which
is a Japan inspired premium cider made
with Fuji apples and various Japanese
flavor combinations Sakura cherry
blossom light key regional recipe which
is the original Fujiyama I've got like
eight other flavors which I'm bringing
out the next kind of couple of years and
you're a comedian and podcast as well
yes yeah well actually actually I did my
first gig you were both there at my
first gig which was which went a lot
better than my second gig first one
always goes grey and you're like yeah
I'm actually a great comedian and the
second good yeah okay what's gonna be a
long journey because after that cuz I've
been writing so much for that first gig
and I was you know because I wanted it
to be soo I wanted to be funny and and
the first gig went well then I was like
well actually I think I've got like 10
minutes of material now so then I went
did this
the second gig there like the next day
actually at two North town and it was a
new material night with an audience of I
think seven or eight people in that huge
room and anyway that ten minutes of
material turned out to only be a few
minutes and to kind of apologizing
welcome to comedy my friend yeah
when is a long hard slog but in addition
to all those things you're a classical
liberal which is a term that people like
to use nowadays everyone is everyone
simultaneously like a Nazi and the
ethical liberal generally yeah those are
the two terms that are now everyone
loves to use what I think I used to when
I was at university I very much I mean I
love Ron Paul Rand Paul I very much kind
of identified with the sort of more
libertarian position but actually as
I've you know I've I've read a lot more
Hayek de Tocqueville and and and I just
feel like actually classical liberalism
is it is almost well I just feel much
more resonant with that visit with that
position and and and also there's
there's almost like a a a kind of
tarnish on the libertarian moniker right
I think people kind of have used it in a
sort of pejorative way for so long I
don't know I think classical liberals
sort of clean a clean vehicle even
though it is a an old liberal it reminds
people that there was an actual
liberalism before the contemporary
misappropriation of the term really I
think so many people and actually I
think that's important to to point out
is that so many people go around calling
themselves liberal when they're
absolutely not liberals and they're the
ones calling everyone fascist when they
are actually sort of intolerant fascists
authoritarians and waiting and so I
think and and you know in discourse
words are important so I think you know
true liberals which I believe are the
the classical liberals need to
reappropriation tenants of classical
liberalism just because most people have
no [ __ ] idea where any of these
things mean well okay so fundamentally
equality civil liberties and and and the
rights of the individual
over the collective a simulant in a
nutshell I think that's pretty much it
in this sort of it's sort of three key
points and from those points you know
spread out so many other facets you know
freedom speech property rights and and
and the law you know and and and the
state's role as essentially enshrining
and enforcing the laws which protect
those original tenants of of classical
liberalism and what do you think the
word liberal means now because sometimes
it looked like we were just touched on
earlier when if someone describes
himself as a liberal I always raise the
eyebrow yeah metaphor that's a problem
right yeah because because you know
these days people think liberalism is
well or progressivism right people think
that slowly making everything more free
for everyone is somehow Liberty but it's
but it's obviously the the actual
inherent lead by by offering loads of
free things via the state your your your
your you're actually violating other
people's Liberty right by by
expropriating their wealth and and and
also essentially enslaving the unborn to
you know huge sums of debt which
actually is how it works out because
most public spending is actually deficit
financed so so yes I think there's an
even even the sort of progressive time
you know it's progressively less free
you know if you if you were a proponent
of that those ideas I think you we are
slowly making society less and less free
and actually you know I think that's one
of my main gripes with the European
Union why I've been a sort of
long-standing even well before the
referendum I was I was very in favor of
leaving the European Union because I
think the trajectory of the European
Union and the and the structures that
they've installed there are well the the
direct opposite of where we want to be
going if we want to live in a free
society
so let's touch it let's let's explore
that a little bit more why do you think
that is there anything that you would
point to in particular well I guess the
the sort of centralization of power and
an unelected unaccountable view is a
recipe for a dictatorship and and and
coupled with a sort of sort of almost
well complicity in an expanding
regulatory framework is like a steadily
growing I did a wave of control over the
sort of many details of everyone's lives
and I just think like that's not a
society I believe in fundamentally
transferring devolving as much power
political power to the individual and to
local communities to to make decisions
for themselves do you think like we're
talking about liberalism and how that
term has been redefined now do you think
it's become essentially a different way
of saying left-wing because like I'll
give you an example
I was recently added to a list by
chortle this comedy yeah the review
website of comedians who are pushing
back against the liberal consensus yeah
right and they had this whole list and
then a guy a very good comedian Gary
Delaney who watches a show sometimes and
he read it anyone this isn't a list of
people pushing back against the liberal
consensus this is a list of people who
are liberal wishing back against
Authority exactly yeah well that's the
thing and it's and it's and it that's
why that's why I you know it was saying
before is that we need to
reappropriation reassociate
the word liberal with the true sense of
the word actual old-school classical
liberalism and because it's it's not
it's not a fair state of affairs that
people who go around thinking that they
are liberal you know are able to use
that term and actually have successfully
appropriated from people who actually
are liberal liberal minded and from your
brief experience of working in the arts
have you noticed that it's not the most
liberal of industries although it claims
to be
well that's that's definitely I mean I
I've been doing stand-up now for well
eight months or something and and and
Dunst was 60 gigs or something and I
have definitely just noticed from other
people's material especially new
material nice you just it's it's almost
like everyone's very consciously trying
to toe the party line and and and any I
was reading a an article West interview
early where he called up another
comedian ask him what he should be
saying on this on this particular point
whether it was politically correct what
was the politically correct way it's
always good to check your thinking yeah
one comedian calling up another one just
to check that he's tearing the party
line and and I mean that's surely not
what what the role of comedian is is to
what - to protect the establishment like
I mean it's not like it's it's just a
weird I mean obviously I'm you know very
new to it and and I'm I'm not I'm not
left-wing I consider myself a liberal in
my own heart but but I would say a
classical liberal outwardly good old
Nazi wanted they wanted as much freedom
but everybody is possible and AB you
have you actually outed you set yourself
as a leader yet to the comedian's or is
this you I think it's very I think I
think it's very easy to to see like I
it's all over my my Twitter I mean I've
been I've debated the stuff on automated
Nick Clegg on this week well again I
mean I mean it I've made no secret of it
because I think these sorts of things
particular
such monumental decisions it requires
you to speak up the interesting thing
that's happening now is actually that
some of those people who are pushing
back against the supposedly liberal
consensus are starting to get traction
because that's what they're doing
yeah you know Jeff Jeff Noah yeah leo
Alastair Williams as well as do you see
his a very funny guy which we know him
well
yeah which which I kind of I was just
like this was an open goal for like any
comedian to do that to do that J but
just no one was doing it no one was
brave enough to actually do it well the
thing with Alistair is that he is very
skilled yeah yeah yeah what he was able
to do is to he did it in a comedy club
that you you will know Topsy yeah
generally attracts a very kind of
progressively crowd and he has the skill
level to be able to to dance that you
know exactly walk that line but if you
go onstage in a normal comedy club and
just got ya break so it's [ __ ] great
because they might think you're being
yeah yeah yeah I do a bit about my mom
being break yeah yeah a tear and then
sometimes at a more progressive clubs
that get so but but it's what kind of
mum them well yeah
what kind of free society are we living
in where you where people feel like they
can't actually voice what they really
think for fear of losing their job like
losing business losing their friends I
mean it's it's not free you know we need
to we need to encourage people to speak
up and and and you know use common sense
and and and and and share their you know
rational conclusions on things without
fear of just being labeled a racist or
or or a Nazi or fascist or you know well
you're going to enjoy might as well
there is it's not just that element of
it although that is a massive problem I
think it's well it's that you know
people who want careers especially
comedians or what careers in the
mainstream media they are really love to
come out because it means that they're
going against the general consensus
which as a result means that their
opportunities will be limited well
exactly and
and you know obviously that has crossed
my mind
but I think it matters more to me like
that we fix society and we and we
correct these that we course-correct and
to into a sort of freer world then then
you know my short-term financial you
know or Korea again but maybe an hour
saying this before like I am optimistic
I do you think people like yourselves
going out and and and and having these
conversations which need to be had is
going to wake people up if it will be
properly work well it's like you've been
you've kind of come out and started
talking about I guess that's the freedom
that comes with having a gold mine this
is what we should do trigonometry
becomes a big success guys when you give
us loads of money on patreon the
SUBSCRIBE start we're gonna buy a
[ __ ] golden yeah just just just buy
low so high that's what that's what
we're gonna do man buy a gold mine
exactly you're like I was gonna make a
comparison between the pig and the
truffle that you just comes across a
deeply auntie submitting you anyway we
just make you are a lifelong Labour
Party exactly no anymore there we go
sorry my Venezuelan side comes out every
now and again
[Music]
it's a really important point you make
we do have this culture of fear that's
why when I say there is a problem with
free speech in this country people go no
it's not you just want to say you know
just drop em bombs and all the rest of
it without repercussions which is true
yeah of course I have a racist voice we
all know however there is a real problem
with free speech in this country and
that people are terrified to voice their
opinions and and comedians are getting
you know visits from the police asking
them about jokes they've told right I
mean that is that is the frightening
reality right I think like how is that
how how is that going on at all poor
people for a tweet they've said I mean
it is it's there's not even the the
illusion of free speech now right people
are just I think that the police are so
politicized about this I mean we've got
knife crying going through the roof and
they're going around chasing people on
calling people up on on tweets and jokes
they've told or or or hate crimes which
essentially is just a crime right like
but they're trying to attach more
gravitas to it by what you're thinking
right like which is the motivation for
it which is which is prosecuting people
for their thoughts indirectly right I
mean it's it's that is not a you know
free society we also have this hate
incident thing yeah well which that is
the thing that really blows my mind
which is essentially that if you do
something and I perceive that you did
well that's what I mean yeah yeah and
and the thing is like they can't you
know normal crime if it's committed
right if they have to investigate it
they have to establish whether it
happened or not but with hate incidents
because they're not crimes they don't
need to establish what happened at all
so if I say you're immediately guilty
yeah so if I say something happened it
happened yeah and then that goes into
recorded statistics and then we have an
epidemic of hate and Britain so what
what are you talking about well and then
that that justifies their narrative to
say oh well brexit has caused a spike in
hate and today
which is just nonsense they're just now
I mean like let's think what is a hate
engine it you can't prove or disprove
you know what's going on in someone's
head yet you know at least and I think
we should we should be very careful
about about this notion of hate hate
speech hate crimes all of that because
fundamentally what it boils down to is
policing people's thoughts
and and you know before they're even
able to speak really I'm sure I mean for
a lot of people hate crimes every time
when something goes in good morning
Britain yeah but actually you were
brilliant on appreciate but actually
that's the thing is I actually don't
feel that that is true in the sense that
whenever I have been on it the feedback
has always been overwhelmingly positive
no I'm the comedy collected the comedy
collective is a group world but have you
tried to put are they are they have they
been bad-mouthing you on the comedy I
have no idea I don't actually you know
that I TV every time I go and good
morning Britain they turn off all the
comments for their videos really yeah
big and I think it's not just me
generally they turn off the comments
because all the stuff that they put out
ordinary people don't agree with it so
whenever I've been on it I suddenly know
by Twitter like the person that they've
had me up against in the bay they always
get a ton of [ __ ] and I always get a ton
of praise yeah right but you wouldn't
know that by looking at the way that the
presenters treat me do you whether they
treat the person doing there's a
conscious thing of trying to mask that
agreement with your position yeah I
think so because if you look on YouTube
actually 90 percent of the good morning
Britain videos have a horrific like to
dislike ratio really they get ratioed
into the ground it's like oh Matthew
Paris embassy we had Matthew Paris on we
must stop brexit and a lot of people
took that to be like us approving of his
position and the ratio that video to the
ground so that's what happens and I
think that the reason
that is they don't want to have to deal
with the reality that the public don't
agree with them mmm yeah you know they
have their own agenda that's driven by a
very London centric they don't even care
they don't even care I mean and and
there is this kind of you know they
think that all brexit ears are like
racist bigots but you know actually I
would say probably most of these sort of
radical remain as actually just don't
really like care much for the working
class you know they have this sort of
disdain for anyone who who who maybe
doesn't share their well view and and
and look I think I've met a lot of
people you know remains that some of my
family also they remain and and and and
I think it's a lot of people who who
have have kind of you know they've done
well for themselves they're on the art
they've got you know you know a house or
a mortgage you know they read the FT and
you know they they almost they almost
don't want to they don't want to mess
with what they've got and you know
they've they've made plans for a future
you know in the European Union they
didn't want I mean the the FT predicted
that they thought that London house
prices could be hit with a forty percent
forty seven percent crash in the event
of a no deal brexit so honestly that's
going to influence the the thinking of
people who own houses hidden in in
London which is I don't think a
coincidence why so many people you know
in Parliament and and and in the media
and people who are doing well themselves
have have have some London property
maybe they that's their their sort of
side business is a bit of property
development that they're all you know
frightened of brexit right because they
want they want to continue what they've
been been doing but but I think and
actually kind of reminds me of de
Tocqueville right you'd say saying
you've got a you've got to step outside
of what might be in your interest in in
the short your short-term financial
interest
and and and and do what's right for
society in the country as a whole and I
just think that we have to put the
country first well see the thing is like
before brexit I may not have agreed with
with what you're saying principally
because I may not share your economic
analysis right I might think well I'm
not sure that breaks it will be good for
the economy but now that we are where we
are I struggle to defend an anti brexit
argument on the simple basis that we had
a vote we made a decision we have to
steer through irrespective of how I
personally feel about yeah and actually
what's interesting is from a statistical
perspective in any binary refere and
there will be a large portion of
essentially don't knows right and
because there's no don't know option
they will invariably go for the status
quo so and I think that works out to
like 32 percent almost the vote right
potentially voted for the status quo but
now if there was a second round
referenda the status quo is to leave
right so so whether people would would
would go back on that I don't know it's
kind of an interesting question you know
what what would be the result would you
have another a big swing even for for
leave because they just want to get it
done and you know don't to prolong the
because it would just open up a whole
new can of worms I think that the thing
that a lot of remain is simply don't
want to address is the fact that what
they're demanding is undemocratic yeah
you can't have a referendum and then
suddenly go oh we didn't like the result
of that well and do you know what that's
kind of quite fascist that's thing this
the the sort of casual dismissal of
democracy for your own short term a
political or financial gain is is what
assured in authoritarian dictatorships
and you know the the Nazi Party and you
know people who who
to look the other way it just gross
violations of of people's freedom and
and and and and civil liberties right so
I think that that there's a lot more in
common in fact with the environment of
just allowing democracy to be trampled
on then then I guess the the people who
are actually just trying to enforce it
and I think the thing another thing that
really when we're talking about fascism
is you know the way that certain they've
made certain words now you know
absolutely toxic like oh he's a lever
you know this must mean that you know
he's racist he's right wing it the idea
that BRICS is purely right-wingers and
nonsense anyway because it's when you
look at the the old-school left of light
but they're all probably well also for
for for their aims you know what they
want to achieve they're not going to be
able to do that and it gives a lot of it
for the radical left is about
consolidating power in their hands right
and and then I'm gonna be able to do
that when all the powers already been
consolidated in Brussels in in in in you
know another set of pairs of hands
well actually we had Paul Embry on the
show I know he caught that up he is a
trade unionist and a socialist and he
was saying look the traditional
left-wing argument in favor of leaving
the European Union is it takes the
shackles off you your government and if
you have a radical labor government you
can then yeah you can actually you you
can make a lot of Socialists changes and
you can have you know Venezuela type of
yeah yeah exactly what I need to lose
and that's pretty much is the only way
is going to happen korben korben
fantastic
the other thing I was going to ask you
as well as you're someone who's
obviously lived abroad
traveled a lot and one of the things I
was talking about on Twitter recently
that
had quite a la présence it's the idea
that a lot of the people who criticize
West West the West yes and civilization
are people who've never experienced
anything except for westernization you
know and there's someone who has
travelled a lot and lived abroad and
seen you know what people live like in
Africa and in other places how do you
feel when people go on about how the
West is this evil oppressive whatever
well I mean I I think you know Western
democracy you know and free markets
essentially free market principles have
raised more people out of poverty around
the world than any other political force
and and and you know you can really you
know I mean we're just so lucky you know
to live where we are and you know that's
why I really do have a sort of
optimistic view of the West I do think
that common sense will will win out and
win the day but but but yeah I think we
are very lucky and I think a lot of
people forget that or just have no real
idea how lucky we are to deliver I mean
yeah what was talking about you being
well what do you have any other kind of
specific points about that like what
like what constant was probably each was
going out a little bit ease a little bit
spoil here yeah yeah oh no I think we
are you know and and and we have the
luxury of you know should we wish to go
out and and stop traffic and and cause a
big a load of chaos for what we might
believe politically you know in many
other countries you just can't do that
I'd like to see them you just you just
can't do that and and it seems you know
it's it's just never good enough for
some people and and and yeah I think
we've we've got a lot - we've got a lot
to congrat
later ourselves on on you know the the
the strides we've made in in in women's
liberation and and and well you know
anti-slavery and all these things but
there's still slavery and and an
oppression of women and gays going on in
so many other countries around the world
which people just don't like you know
that's what really people should be
protesting they should be standing
outside the embassies of of you know
Saudi Arabia and and we're not just our
Arabian baby but but but but you know
there's so many so many so many so many
more important things to be up in arms
about which are going unchallenged I'm
pretty sure there's never been more
slavery in his know for the world there
are more there are more slaves in in in
the world than there ever have been one
thing I wanted to talk to you about a
little bit as well was reality TV so you
created this reality TV well I didn't
create it oh no no no I didn't create it
no I
I basically was doing this business I
was a university and left left leaving
Edinburgh to focus on this business
which was actually a tech company back
then and and I had been approached by
email when I was at Edinburgh by this
production company quill monkey Kingdom
who had seen me in Tatler's little black
book rather than baracy me but but so
they asked me if I would consider making
this pilot for them and I actually
ignored them for about a year and then I
was back in London and they got back in
touch and said they really wanted to
find people they've got Commission to
make a pilot from efore and so I I kind
of helped them come up with a storyline
and and and and found some of my friends
who I thought were that way inclined and
because it's how much of it because
there's always this argument
particularly with love Ireland done all
of this how much of that is real and how
much of that is scripted and also as
well and what I want to touch on a
little bit is how much responsibility do
production companies have to the people
who they go on yeah because that is it's
a hot topic yeah I mean if I had a penny
for every time someone asked me how real
it is I would probably have to go it's a
fair question because I think part of
the reason for its success is is that
the the blurred lines of fact in fiction
and and and the audience is almost like
a puzzle to try and work out what's real
and what's not you know you're you're
you're constantly asking as I think that
can't be real they're not actually
obviously the way you'll bump into
someone in the middle of the street
or with what was called a random bump in
moment those are not real because you
have to set up like for cross shooting
cameras and yeah but as much as the
producers will or can't have control
over they want everything to be real in
terms of the relationships friendships
yes like disagreements arguments
breakups and all that stuff to the point
where like they call you every day to
find out what's going on what you're
planning on doing to check your thinking
and and so you kind of you know tell
them what you so it's very like intense
and and takes up a lot of time you know
not just filming but you know sharing
your thinking with them and and sort of
experience you know how bad things could
get and just country yeah but but but
yeah I I think it's a weird like I'm you
know this isn't how they would sell it
but I kind of have fathers he thought a
lot about it and it it almost it's quite
kind of postmodern in a way because it
creates two realities within one reality
and the the reality on camera becomes a
reality in and of itself which everyone
who's involved is kind of complicit in
and doesn't speak about the things which
they might all know isn't true because
it's kind of like in the interest of
furthering the the the storyline as so
obviously the production don't like that
but like a lot of people I know have
kind of maybe had relationships of
convenience and and and camera airtime
right like so they so they've kind of
but then you know you if you're both
willfully involved in something like
that then soon it becomes real and then
you're like well what is you may have
got together for that reason but then
you know you're still together so are
you actually I mean it sad [ __ ] yeah
this is why when Francis and I decided
through the show we made a clear
distinction the beginning it's funny to
the extent to which all TV
is massage as someone who's done the bit
of it I know like when you go in good
morning Britain it's not like you just
walk into a room and start talking they
want the headlines there's quite a lot
of prep they call you up before when
you're sitting there they're doing your
makeup there's a particular person who's
very clearly very skilled
psychologically comes in and just chats
to you as like as while it's happening
yeah you know what they're trying to do
is tease you just past the point which
you were prepared to go to you so that
you say a thing that's a little bit
extra yeah because all they care about
is getting their show those clips in the
headlines right and there and there you
know and they'll keep badgering you to
get that point that they want that that
little headline snippet which they can
use and get in the Daily Mail and you
know which I think why the why new media
like podcasts like YouTube is having
such a breakthrough because as you say
it allows for an authentic conversation
of a conversation like we haven't sat
you down to try and get you to say
something that you don't want to say
quite the opposite we want you to say
what you actually think but yeah I mean
I guess you know in answer to your other
question I don't know how other shows do
it and how you know how much of sort of
their duty of care they fulfill I think
made in truck in the early days I think
it was when no one really knew what it
was going to be right and no one and no
one really knew how big these shows were
going to get because it was kind of well
at the same time as TOWIE we were kind
of sort of the first shows like that
which which which kind of catapulted all
of us into sudden I don't really well I
guess Fame or whatever and you know we
were we were recognized you know
everywhere we went but and and and
certainly some people were
stable enough to deal with that and
certain other people didn't you know
weren't and and I you know it's all a
lot of people kind of breakdown from
that from their from the from the show
and the sort of whole fallout from it so
that's really interesting so tell us a
little bit about that because I think
most ordinary people will always wonder
like this guy's a millionaire he's
getting a lot is famous she's got you
know hot women walking up to him on the
street blah blah blah yeah sorry let me
just finish this question right like
what is the the thing that drives people
crazy or that makes people go off the
rails when that happens well okay so I
think the nature of these shows
presenting themselves and the and the
actual end product as reality you know
then dealing with the cast members you
know saying that all has to be real you
you lead certain people to almost become
caricatures of themselves and they do it
and when their lives become so deeply
intertwined with what's going on
on-screen and and and the sort of the
chaos and and and drama that comes with
that they kind of lose track of what is
real and what isn't and who they really
are so they lose self-awareness and and
it's quite it's it's been quite
interesting obviously a lot of the cast
well pretty much all of the cast I knew
before from you know from from childhood
right from from school and stuff like
that and and so it was it was it was
interesting to see some people and how
how it affected them you know I'm
knowing this elite named Yoshi I just
off camera here
I'll tell you but because right now we
have got especially young people this
obsession of fame fame sake if you ask
you know if you form a teacher you are
sees kids what they want to be when they
go out want to be famous well nobody
want to be famous was a an amazing
football no it's famous for and it's
it's it's amazing because it's sort of
fed right into the hands of big tech and
you know wanting to kind of share their
entire lives with the algorithm which is
eventually going to kind of know
everything about you and it's going to
be able to make better decisions for you
and for your life then you will write
you know it's gonna be able to say well
actually don't go for this girl because
you know you know you know you're much
more compatible and it'll be right and
getting that way and but I do think that
you know Fame is an unnatural phenomenon
right you know you you would never in
nature right if when we were sort of
living our sort of tribal
hunter-gatherer lives be able to become
hugely famous right there was no there
was no vehicle before the printing press
or or you know obviously there were
there's sort of eventually those kinds
of kings and and and royalty and stuff
like that but but it's an unnatural
thing and so I think psychologically we
don't really know how to deal with it
and it's only it's all mistake excites
people and and and the idea of it I
think definitely it's it's it goes hand
in hand this sort of desire for fame and
these sort of treating famous people
like they are almost kinds of you know
demigods right like people did people
treat them like they're they're bigger
and more important than just the average
goings on the street and and and yeah I
guess it's I guess it's I don't know
where I'm going with that
well Paula's going to say part of the
problem for me that I have with reality
TV and and I don't think a lot of people
understand this when they're getting
into it is essentially it's a true
I've soap opera hmm so they take aspects
of your character they sort of mishmash
it together and then they create this
character of it which is part of you but
doesn't in no way represents no all of
you but that's a well everybody the
general public thinks that you are
well that's the thing and and I think a
lot of people would assume because I was
on that show because of how they
presented me really a you know to some
extent without my you know a permission
as like some spoiled rich kid you know
that's had everything handed to him on a
plate and and that can be you know
further from the truth
I mean I'm I'm self-made man I've never
had any money given to me my dad is
small and so yeah so it is kind of like
you can't you you can't control that you
can't control how they edit you can't
control I present you you've just got to
do your best to give the a good and fair
representation of who you are in
opportunities like this and an outside
of of that very limited window into a
fake reality almost all right well
there's one question that I wanted to
ask and the left-wing thing that we
talked about before in light of the fact
that two people have committed suicide
who have gone on what's it love island
and then ya know two former contestants
have committed suicide
I think of some people I want to go on
and also as well we see somebody
committed suicide because of Jeremy Cole
how much responsibility do these
production companies have to the people
that go on it's supposed to regarding on
sorry guys so yeah actually I think they
do have more responsibility than they
[Music]
then they realize or maybe they do look
for them it's
about making a good TV show right that's
that's that that's their main priority
and often that comes at the expense of
people's mental well-being and and
there's a sort of an awareness of that
in producers like they know that it's
you know they know and and you know they
they'll pay sort of lip service to their
their obligations they'll get a you know
psychologist to interview you or
whatever but I mean it's not like
rigorous psychoanalysis and a lot of
people have things which they just don't
share with the psychologist like a lot
of people who go on these shows I think
are actually you know they might pretend
to have loads of money but there may be
like quite a lot of debt or they're
they're desperate and they think that
going on love island is going to
suddenly solve all their problems but
almost like the nature of something like
love Island
you know the way that they have is this
whole new boatload of fresh faces in
every year it's almost like designed to
make the country forget about the last
group of people do you mean so so
they've got like a year to just make it
right and if they don't and if they
don't feel like it's going as well as
they expected it to there must be a huge
sense of like like well pressure and and
depression and you know I can completely
see how you can spiral out of that
people who aren't necessarily stable
enough to deal with the inevitable
decline in work that comes with doing as
those shows people people are expecting
to just be the next I don't know example
yeah but I know you mean it's almost
like you have to be mentally unstable to
want to get sure I mean it's a show
that's really bad for people who I
mentor yeah anyway we're gonna wrap up
so on that happy note we always ask one
more question which is what's the one
thing that no one is talking about that
we should be talking about everyone
should be talking about classical
liberalism as we've done for an hour
well or at least they should look into
and and a very good book I could
recommend people read is
fatal conceit by Frederick Hayek
fantastic action of stuff well just
remind us the name of your business
again
Yoshii cider yoshisada get the cider and
i can say i don't drink but if i was
going to have a relapse i would
certainly be fantastic just in case this
goes out during or before item Brad you
want to plug yeah so I've got a two week
run at the Pleasants ice dome from 11
p.m. to 12 p.m. so be there book tickets
on my Instagram from the 9th to the 25th
and not not the 13 your Twitter is my
twitter is Francis Boone will put in the
video thank you very much for tuning in
as always follow us at trigger pod on
all the social media give us an iTunes
review remember to subscribe to the
channel click the bell button to get the
notifications and we will see you in a
week from now with another great episode
see you later guys take care
[Music]
here's the form that you were asked to I
said by signing this contract this is
the UNICEF on campus SOAs right he was
asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti religion nante atheism
I think you're doing some quite
complicated mental arithmetic to offset
the party people didn't think you were
funny I think the reality performing
autopsies ricotta
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you're just I mean you're
just so fing abettin outright you know
alright now that we got there in the end
you did do the good thing about people
that are teeth needed right as I know
I've got in each one of them is I
haven't got any racist sexist homophobic
jokes I have been a student at the
University where you can't make any joke
about anything if these poor little
local students get upset with drinking
get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't know I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become a member when Gareth Bale
right when from Tottenham to round the
tree the guy left a perfectly good club
for more money everybody feels like
we're we're all kind of under arrest
we're all everything we say can and will
be used against us in the court of
public opinion and they're coming for
the comedian's first because we're we're
the ones that is you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why this story's got the
resonance though it has
[Music]